>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Georgette Dorn: My
name is Georgette Dorn
and I'm chief the Hispanic division.
It's a great pleasure to
welcome Franklin Knight
to the Library of Congress.
He is a professor Emeritus
at John Hopkins University
and he has written many,
many books on Cuba,
on Latin America, on Brazil.
The famous lecturer and he is
also on the board of Handbook
of Latin American studies for
which we owe him a deep depth
of gratitude.
I want to ask you to
please close all your iPads
and electronics conveyances
thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Franklin Knight:
Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here and
I must start with an apology.
When I was invited, I had the
illusion that this would be one
of my traditional lectures on
such a splendid elevating subject.
That is to say it will
be accompanied
by appropriate samples
all through the delivery.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Franklin Knight: Well, that's why
I'm apologizing we couldn't do that.
But maybe we can come
back and arrange something
at the Christmas party,
[inaudible], something.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Franklin Knight: What I wanted
to do is very simple and actually
in the first two slides, this one
and the next, you have a lecture
so you can, since we
have no samples,
you know what I'm going to say?
You can fall asleep if
the chair is comfortable
or you can leave quietly.
I usually say that, to look at
rum, you look at rum by the numbers
and in fact number 1 is that
rum is the distilled alcohol
from the sugar cane.
And 2, there are only two
ways that rum is made.
The first is to make it directly
from the juice of the sugar cane
which is how you get white
rum, that's mostly done.
Today that method is employed
exclusive by the French
and presumably by the Guatemalans.
[ Laughter ]
All the producers of rum
in the world and it goes
under different names as we'll see
shortly, produce it from molasses
which is a byproduct
for producing sugar.
There are three types of rum despite
what the marketers are trying
to put in.
There is white rum, 80% of
the rum consumed is white rum
and all rum begins as white rum,
because it's a distilled spirit just
like any distilled spirit will do.
So when you talk about
white rum, you're talking
about sugar cane alcohol.
And the reason one never wastes
time talking about that is
that they're really
no subtle qualities
in white sugar cane alcohol.
It's stronger or it's weaker and
it blends like all other things.
When I give a lecture on this, we
start and I say don't drink it.
Just put your finger in it,
put it on the tongue so to get
to know what sugar cane
alcohol really tastes like.
What is more, or what is
preferable for people who like
to indulge is regular colored
rum called gold rum sometimes.
And that's usually put in
casks, white oak casks and aged
from 1 to 4, 5 or 6 years.
That's called batch rum.
And that's the second
largest component of rum
because it's cheaper of course.
The third group is what's called
aged rum or anejo or premium rums.
That must be aged a minimum of 6
years, usually 7 or more up to 100
and it's blended just like whiskey.
So where you get your
qualitative distinction,
mainly is in this third category
of rum, the premium blended rums.
And again, when I go on to
talk about it, I will tell you
that recently, the market has
been assaulted by all sorts
of premium rums claiming to be 20,
30, 40 50 years old and is all made
over a weekend but
you can find that out.
And I'll tell you the secret of
how you find a genuine aged rum
from one of these weekend rums.
There are four characteristics
that connoisseurs look
for in assessing rum
and they're very simple.
The first is the color, it
should have this nice color
and I'll come back to
talk about this a little
and that's why it's
always suspicious
to buy expensive premium rums
which are not in a clear bottle.
You have to establish a reputation
before you can do that such
as Pampero Aniversario
or Zacapa from Guatemala.
Those have the distinction,
well, a Zacapa, we don't know.
I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But they have the reputation
that the rums are good enough,
that people will believe them
even if they're wrapped and left.
The second is a bouquet,
that's really very important.
White oak gives a peculiar
bouquet to aged rums.
And that can be blended,
complicated and ameliorated
by whatever special
additive that's put
in to make the rum suave or gentle.
In the case of Zacapa, we
know, of course its Sherry.
In the case of something
like Royal Crown
from Trinidad, its
angostura bitters.
In the case of Jamaica
Appleton Estates Special,
a rum of singular distinction, the
rum by which all rums are judged,
it's all spice and
some other things,
so there's a secret ingredient.
And the bouquet will always stay
if the rum is aged in white oak
because that's the
basis of the bouquet.
If it's infused with any sort
of thing, if you open the bottle
for a short time, the
bouquet disappears
and you know you have
been defrauded,
not an uncommon experience.
The third is the smoothness,
good rums are smooth.
And a lot of these bouquet
rums because they are forced
over a weekend or so, are not
smooth, they're a little harsh
and you again will feel that
which is why the sampling
of rums is an important part
of the discussion of rums.
And I'd like to say that the fourth
and final one is equally important.
There should be no harsh aftertaste.
After all, when you open the
bottle you should encourage
to finish the bottle.
And if it has this kick, you're not
going to be encouraged to do that.
You're going to blend
it with something else.
So let's start at the
very beginning.
How do you make consumable alcohol?
There are three ways.
I'm giving you all these
mathematical things, 1, 2, 3.
The first of course, the
oldest way is fermentation.
You leave most things out in
the sugar cane, it will ferment.
That's how we got grapes fermenting
and wine became the first distilled,
oh sorry alcoholic beverage consumed
widely in all wide growing areas.
The second is after discovery of
fire is brewing, boiling the stuff,
creates ales, beers,
filthy stuff but good.
And the third, which became
popular in the 12th Century,
actually beginning
in the 13th Century
with the Fourth Crusade
was sugar cane alcohol.
Now a lot of books
on rum will tell you
that rum is a West Indian
invention, that's not true.
A lot of other books will
tell you that rum grew
out of the Levantine Mediterranean
out of Lebanon and Syria
and that's partly true but
Marco Polo, in 1224 writes
that he tasted a wine made
from the sugar cane in China.
So we know that since the beaker,
the instrument of distillation is
of Chinese origin and that beakers,
9000 years old have been discovered,
we know that the Chinese were
distilling all sorts of stuff,
mainly rice but also sugar cane.
And an aside I will tell you
that the sugar cane comes from
and I'm going to sort of go
over that part, comes Indonesia,
domesticated in Indonesia.
Once through China, India and
then came to the Middle East.
And in fact as late
as the 15th Century,
in most of the Ottoman Empire,
sugar was called Indian salt.
And in fact this is when the
coffee which is a beverage taken
in Arabic countries with
salt became blended with milk
and Indian salt which is sugar.
You can still get that
confection in Vienna today.
So these rums are the basis,
these sugar canes, different types
of sugar cane are the
basis for distilling rum.
Here we have some types
of sugar cane.
These are exactly what the
sugar cane looks like and the,
these containers will have the
juice in the old primitive form.
If you go to Madeira, you
will still see some of those.
This is the mill, old rotary mill.
This is an improvement made in the
Middle of 15th Century in Sicily.
So for a long time it was
called the Sicilian Mill,
a double roller or a triple roller.
This is the improved
Americanized version.
That's an American triple roller
made in West Point, New York.
Both of these are from the
old Cuban sugar estates,
not working now obviously.
These are the pots.
You can see that they
would boil it in the open
and when the sugar did not
crystalize then you got the raw
material for your distillation
product.
So if you want to call it rum
or [room] as the French call it.
They were the first to do it.
Or it could call it as the
Brazilians do, cachaca,
aguardiente de cana or rum.
That is a Brazilian cachaca bottle.
Some people would recognize that.
I would love to have the
challenge of drinking that dry.
It would be a little
challenging I think.
I retired so I could do
something lectures like these
but the opportunities
have not been frequent.
Some of these exclusive
rums can be very expensive.
That's not a very good picture,
but this is from the rum museum
in Port au Spain, Trinidad and
this is a special rum that was made
or blended which was sold for almost
a one quarter of million per bottle.
I asked them to let me sample it,
because I have some credentials
but they wouldn't let me do
it for good reason I suppose.
These are the white oak casks
that white rums are blended in.
And on that display
you can see that most
of the rums are actually
variations of white rums
and that wouldn't make
much distinction.
There is some colored rum there.
But none of this in this
batch would be a premium rum,
that is to say aged over
seven years or so or blended.
Although, they did tell me, this is
from Worthy Park Estate, Jamaica,
and they just went into the
rum business a few years ago
which is why most of their
rums is still white rums.
This is the major white
rum, they sell Rum-Bar rum.
It's terrible but since rum is a
blend, it doesn't really matter,
you're going to put water
in it or juice in it or milk
in it or coffee or something.
But they said by 2018 they will
have colored, gold rum and then
in the 2020s they will
have premium rums.
So as I mentioned, 80% of all
rums, white rum and earlier
in the beginning of rum in the New
World because rum travels with sugar
as I said, I byproduct, it only
became a premium product that is
to say people would specifically
make rum in the 18th Century
and we will come to that, so
that a lot of sugar cane growers
of the 18th Century including the
estates [inaudible] Simon Bolivar
did not make sugar.
There are 5000 acres of
sugar cane made only alcohol,
distilled alcohol.
But it was carried in casks like
these and you can see again,
the relationship to the
whole European distillation,
all distilled spirits tended
to be put in casks like that
after it became popular in the 15th
or late 14 and early 15th Century
and if fact if you do the history
of any type of distilled alcohol,
that's when it becomes
a commercial product.
This is the Appleton Estate Special.
They don't have their
highest brand there
which is the blue label,
a 21 year old.
That's the rum that opened the
store window in 2012 at Harrods,
the only rum displayed
at 300 pounds per bottle.
I wouldn't buy, but I did taste
and it was very smooth,
absolutely divine.
I've been hinting to one of my
friends that in my retirement
that might be a good
thing to give to me
to keep me indoors in the winter.
So how did rum come
to the New World?
Well, it came in the long
journey from the Mediterranean
through southern Spain
to the Atlantic Islands.
Now, sugar was not an
important product in Europe
for the simple reason that sugar was
derived from honey and other types
of products and was
a minor actually.
It was not a consumer popular
item that's the sort of luxury,
until it got to about Madeira.
And the reason it became
important in Madeira which is one
of the major producers along
with the Canary Islands was
that when the wine industry moved
from the mainland of Portugal
onto the islands, Madeira decided
because it had the growing
characteristics of Porto,
to ship port wine back to Portugal.
Well the people in Porto
would not agree to this,
so the Madeirans did one up
in them, they simply blended
with distilled alcohol, called
it Madeira, varied it and it took
to the market with vengeance,
still a good product.
This happens to be one sugar
cane fields which do both sugar
and I'll just go through
them quickly
because sugar cane
fields look the same.
First was Cuba, the second
was Jamaica, this is Brazil.
What you do get in
variation is that the extent.
For example, it's dying out now
in Cuba but if you go from Jamaica
or if you go from Madeira where
sugar cane estate is all the size
of this room, to Jamaica to
where it's about 3, 400 acres,
to Cuba where it's
about 3, 4000 acres.
Then you go to Brazil where
it's about 30, 40,000 acres,
you can see the production of scale.
But the big difference today is
that sugar is not as important
as it used to be nor is rum.
And so most of the sugar cane
growing is done for making ethanol
which of course goes into blend
with gasoline or to be used
as a substitute for gasoline.
So how did rum move from
being a marginal byproduct
as it were to being mainstream?
Ah, you can blame that
again on the pirates.
They know a good thing when they
find it and they found that out
between about 1650 and 1720.
The age of piracy and what they
did was to capture when they went
on land, not just bullion,
gold silver, slaves, sugar,
coffee, tobacco, but also rum.
And they didn't resell the rum
in most cases, they consumed it.
Well, about the beginning
of the 18th Century
when we had these large wars
in European countries are
establishing peace beyond the line,
Admiral Edward Vernon, after whom
Washington's estate Mount Vernon is
named was short over ales that
they supplied to their sailors.
And of course, one
of the big problems
until the 18th Century was how
to neutralize the scurvy
attacks among men
at sea for a very long time.
So they used a lot of things.
Mainly they used citric
acid, citric juices.
They even tried unboiled eggs
until they found that some
of them were probably not the best
things after several weeks or months
at sea and they hit up on rum.
Well, rum unnoticed that pirates
never seemed to have scurvy
and they always seemed to
be bolder than they should.
So beginning in 1739, during
the War of Jenkins' Ear.
He ordered that all sailors
and soldiers on his fleet
and his fleet included at the
time, Laurence Washington,
the oldest sickly brother
of George Washington,
who owned that little estate
that later became Mount Vernon.
It wasn't as impressive as
George made it but he owned it.
And he was very impressed by this.
I think not by the behavior of
Vernon, but by the daily ration
of rum, because this is what
Vernon said at the time.
It should be cut with water
but never blended so much
that when taken will
not encourage a rabbit
to bite the head off a bulldog.
So there we get it,
this is the grog.
And it's called grog, old grog
because Vernon always went
around the, his ships
wearing a grogram coat.
So they called him, there
goes old grog and so his order
of ration was called old grog,
it's blended with citric juice,
lime juice and water and we still
make grog today although we boil it
and you put in some spices
and it's a marvelous thing.
One of the big pioneers
in popularizing it was a
pirate called Henry Morgan,
an indentured worker who came out
to Jamaica and ended up his life
as Lieutenant governor of
Jamaica and had the decency
to die just before his main
spot Port Royal disappeared
in an earthquake.
His timing was always impeccable.
Ask the Spaniards about that,
after Drake he is the other one.
>> Is that the Captain Morgan?
>> That is the Captain Morgan but
the rum unfortunately is terrible.
It's what we call airport rum.
You know, it's the type of
thing that you find in airports
and no serious drinker
takes it seriously.
I have never had more than the
first taste but I've been at this
since my infancy and I'm still
hopeful that I will continue
to being in good shape
based on this.
I want to read through all of
this but what it says is one
in 1735 talking about this
practice that they had found
in Cartagena on the Colombian coast.
Where the officers drank distinct
beverages, brandy and wines
and the lower classes
drank a product extracted
from the sugar cane, agua ardiente
de cana which is white rum and also
that he was beginning to say that
it seemed that they benefitted
from drinking it at 11:00 every day.
It was good for the appetite.
Well if you're drunk at midday it
must be a good day which is why
when I give these lectures
nobody ever complains
because by the time
I'm finished they're
in an elevated state of view.
Here we have this sort of marketing
labeling and the competition of rum
which is going for a long time,
this is Havana Club
and you have two left.
And the left hand side is the what I
call the authentic Havana Club made
by Cubans and on the right is
Bacardi's Havana Club it used
to own the label for Havana Club,
it lost it or gave it up allowed
to be sold legally
in the United States.
Now there is a recent court ruling
that since President Obama went
to Cuba that Cubans made Pernod
Ricard there vendors may sell Havana
Club when the embargo is
dropped in the United States.
But Barcadi and Cuban, the Cuban
government and then Cuban government
and Pernod Ricard have been
fighting this case since 1970.
So it's not likely to be
settled in our lifetime.
You have a lot of rums, the
important rums I've talked about,
you know, Barcardi, Pampero
Aniversaro of Barbados,
some of the oldest, continuously
produced rum distillers in the world
or Wray and Nephew of Jamaica.
They respect conventions and labels.
That is to say that
you can actually,
because these are legitimate
concerns that will set the standards
and follow the conventions.
But then you have on
the market a lot of.
[ Laughter ]
Well, [inaudible].
I am sure that some
polishes would say
that is a locker room type of rum.
[ Laughter ]
But you also get the case of Zacapa.
Now Zacapa is a good rum.
Made [inaudible] and
they used to sell a rum
which was on the left hand side.
You can read it I think
but it says 23 years old.
And they have a 25 year
old and a 30 year old.
And I couldn't for the life
of me find what was different
between the 23 year old, the 25
year old and the 30 year old.
I thought it was the same rum.
And somebody, you shouldn't
fire people
when they're doing something wrong.
Somebody was fired from the company,
pointed out that ain't
23 years old at all.
So they were forced in
fact, to retrack the label
because it violated
the convention of rum.
When you label a rum by years,
it means that that is the
youngest rum in the batch, blended.
So a 23 year old rum can
have a 50 year old rum,
but it cannot be called 50 year old.
It can only be called
23, the lowest.
And if it has 7, 10, 15 and
20, the same thing goes.
So Zacapa cleverly, they have now
taken the wrapper off the bottle
but they call the rum.
You might be able to,
well you can't see there.
We should be able to get that.
Solera 23 merely indicating
the technique of production.
Needless to say they put in Sherry
cask, date it 2000 feet so they say
above sea level, I haven't actually
physically gone to the plant
and they rack it like
Sherry is in the sun.
So you get that nice,
smooth, manifested detective
of the Sherry taste
when you take Zacapa.
Now Zacapa has a 30 year old rum
which I will say is very
smooth and very good.
So developing for the taste
of rum started from the Navy
and anything sailors do at sea,
they will do worse on land.
So naturally they took their
habits and they had this sort
of substantiation that you know,
Admiral Vernon approves of this.
And by the way, the rum ration
that Vernon started in 1739,
was a standard issue until 1970 in
the British Navy, so it endured.
And everyone, including Edward
Long, the famous historian would say
that if Vernon says it's
good, it must be good.
And then the second approval came
from none other than
Benjamin Franklin.
Never saw anything new
that he didn't like.
And this was new, and this was not
only likeable, it was loveable.
And I will go on to give some proof.
Now of course it says
how you have to drink it
and that the latter part it, I'm
trying to go through because I want
to have some questions but
there will be a copy online
so you can easily go back and
read this stuff if you want to.
But what it says is that even
when you drink rum in excess,
it's good for you and I like that.
Anybody who will make that sort
of decoration is my friend.
But rum became really very important
in the early American colonies
or the major American colonies
just before independence,
because it became the second
largest employer of labor.
And in fact it generated much of the
wealth of the northeast at the time.
And the consumption in the British
North America was tremendous,
five times what it
was in British Ailes
where people were easily captured
because they were unsteady
on their feet.
Rum helped in the conquest
of the United States.
And in fact even George
Washington admitted
that when he signed the
Naval Armament Act in 1794
in which he said, there
should also be allowed 1 pint
of distilled spirits per
day or in lieu thereof,
one quart of beer a day per person.
That's my type of man.
That's what I call hefty drinking.
But look what we have from another
of the fathers of the country,
Thomas Jefferson's wine cellar.
Now you know that Jefferson
was himself a winemaker.
Curiously enough he lists
none of the Monticello wines
in his wine cellar
which led me to believe
that they didn't meet his
standards having lived in France,
so they were for his friends.
I, I know the idea, I used
to serve my seminar Sherry,
but I wouldn't serve them
the sherry I drank at home.
They had to get something a
little less for their homes.
But 15 bottles of Madeira, 4
bottles of common Lisbon wine,
54 bottles of cider and 53%
of the wine cellar is 83
bottles of Barbadian rum.
Lawrence as you know and
George also visited Barbados.
Lawrence spent some time in
Barbados got very fond of Mount Gay
and when he came back, the entire
Virginian aristocracy were drinking
rum, mainly Mount Gay.
Later on, Franklin Delano Roosevelt
who spent some time in Haiti,
came back and served Barbancourt.
Barbancourt is a fine rum but
it's a French rum like Clement.
I'll talk about that.
It's a different type of
rum if you really like rum.
There's no reason why you can't
like Clement but Barbancourt
and Clement pretend to make
a Cognac and I always say
to my French Italian
friends and Haitian friends,
when I want a Cognac,
I'd buy a Cognac.
When I want a good rum, I'd buy a
good rum and one should not confuse
that but to each its taste.
It's a matter of taste.
So let me run through
a few factoids in rum.
I already mentioned the
high consumption rate here.
In 1770, the population
of 1.7 million British North America
consumed 7.5 million gallons of rum,
half produced locally, half
imported from the Caribbean.
I ran through the figures
and I figured that 4
out of every 5 persons were
either women or children.
Women were doing all the work,
children were supposed to be
in school, yet British North
Americans average 4.2 gallons
of rum per year.
How did they ever win
the war of independence?
Because they were certainly
more unsteady than the British.
British consumption at that time
was less than 1 gallon per person.
In 1770, British North America
had 18 sugar refineries,
118 distilleries, 51
in Massachusetts.
No wonder they threw
tea into the sea.
These guys were unsteady
on their feet.
It was not necessary
of political statement.
It was a physical fact.
So they go.
And one by 1740 already, rum was
beginning to be in all the books
of the planters and the Caribbean,
second most important cash
product that they had.
Ward family in 1703 in Barbados
and Wray and Nephew in 1749.
But when we begin to think of rum,
the thing about the early rum,
the 18 Century rum, is
that is mainly white rum
or its rum that's crudely
aged in white oak.
After time they found that
white oak was the only oak
that would give the chemical
reaction that makes rum acceptable.
But it still had a lot
of impurities in it.
And the other thing was that
a lot of the sailors thought
that you could store
rum in lead barrels.
So it was not surprising that
lead poisoning became particularly
serious in the 18th
and 19th Century.
Then we become with Facundo Bacardi
who started what we call the
modern age of rum making.
Bacardi was a Catalan
who came to Cuba
where his brother ran the
sugar business until 2014,
sadly destroyed the factory
but until 2014 you could still
see the original Bacardi factory
in Santiago, Cuba.
And what he decided to do
was to experiment with it
to see how you could blend these
aging rums which he started
and by 1862, he had come on with
a product that was acceptable,
despite the fact that the
more successful he was,
the larger the number of rat
bats flew from the distillery.
So most Cubans call it rat bat
liquor, but it didn't matter
to the Bacardi family,
because the king liked it
and gave them a gold medal
and they were on their way.
About the same time,
the Clement family
in Martinique started
the same process.
And all new rum makers began to do
the same scientific aging blending
of rums and removing more and
more of impurities that came
with the whole process
of sugar making.
So that's how we got all of
these different types of rums.
The batch rums which are the
ones from about 2 to about 6yrs
and those tend to be common
according to the batch that's made.
I'll sort of skip these,
because we've talked a
little bit about them.
And go through to the
traditions of rum and how one,
this is the blue label in
the middle, the 21 year old
as I have said actually last week
for the first time I've had
the pleasure of sampling
that of Toronto, Canada
because I have good friends
who know my weakness and indulge it.
This is the Harrods window in 2012.
So here are some sampling
of premium rums.
I've already talked about that, said
why I don't talk about white rums
and all these different, what
is ginger rums and coconut rums
and all these things that
marketers are trying to use
to attract sort of wider audience.
One of the characteristics of rum
is that it's really very versatile.
Anything you blend
with rum, rum improves.
So it's good at the beginning and
it gets better with whatever you do.
And the three ways of drinking it
is if you're going to buy a good rum
and you really want to
know how good it is,
you really have to have it neat.
You must have it straight and you
must have it in the sort of Cognac,
the glass with things you can rub.
It's really very good.
You can drink it at all
seasons of the year.
This is what's so marvelous
about it.
Straight in the winter, blended in
the summer and somewhere in between
in the spring and the fall.
I won't go into the airport
varieties of rum and we'll now start
about the connoisseurship of rum.
You look four characteristics,
color, bouquet, smoothness
and the absence of
a harsh aftertaste.
And the real color, although
you can get a darker rum,
some people like Gosling's,
Bermudans especially
which is a very, very dark rum.
But again, Gosling's is not
a sippier rum on its own
because it's supposed to be
the basis for dark and stormy,
mixing it with ginger beer which
gives it that really kicking nice,
not a mule kick but a
nice stimulating urge.
The real color though of good
premium rums should be honey-like,
that sort of smooth, not
too dark, not too light
and that was again why I said that
if you wrap the bottle you can do
that before you buy the product and
that is an important part of it.
The bouquet, these lectures
must be given with samples
because it's important that when
I talk about bouquet you get it.
It is a really unique,
individualistic bouquet.
Because if you are spending a lot
of time indulging in this habit,
you can from the bouquet
determine some of the rums.
You can, Havana Club for example or
Santiago which is the old Matusalem
which they lost the label for,
the copyright, trademark for,
is blended with molasses.
So every 5 years, in the aging
process, they open the cask
and they infuse the molasses
and they turn it, you rack it.
And so you can in Havana club
detect the molasses and also
in the bouquet, the
molasses comes through.
And a good premium rum or let
me backtrack and personalize it
since all alcohol consumption
has a personal date.
Everyone has a favorite beer.
When I came to this country I
couldn't understand how they could
drink that stuff having
come from a country
that produced really good beer.
But then I realized, it's
marketing, it's laws.
So we improved the beer where I was.
And it's a question of the
reaction with your palate.
So I might have a favorite and
you might have another favorite
and we're both right,
it's very good.
But bouquet is really
good test of authenticity
because if you open a bottle of
rum, one of the characteristics
of truly aged rum is
that it maintains its
bouquet almost indefinitely,
almost because it's going to
absorb moisture from the air.
Meanwhile, artificial rums,
these weekend, one week deals
that are now popping up all
over will lose their bouquet
because it's an artificial infusion.
If you put it in, it will come
out and it will fade quickly.
Some smooth examples, Doorly is
the most popular Barbadian rum
but mine happens to,
my favorite happens
to be Cockspur VSOR,
very special old rum.
It's a rum that's so smooth you
will forget you're drinking it
or El Dorado.
There's Havana Club and there's
examples, the one, this is Pompero,
Centenario, sorry from
Venezuela, really good rum,
much better than [inaudible]
which started making rum
in 1996 but calls itself 1796.
Royal Oak has, it used to be
a Venezuela rum but it came
from Angostura, Venezuela
in the Venezuelan Revolution
of 1898, it moved to Trinidad.
Makes Angostura bitters,
some of you might know it.
And it's one of the
things they put in it.
Two good Venezuelan, Pampero in the
Leather Jacket and Barcelo Brugal
from the Dominican Republic,
also so really good rums.
There's Cockspur but the very
left is my favorite when I need
to celebrate or relieve my
depression I'd grab a bottle
of that, very good.
My son and I will usually
retreat or when Barcelona loses.
[ Laughter ]
Some more of the rums
that you will have.
This is Puerto Rican rum Don Q
on the left, very, very good,
hard to get sometimes on the market.
And there is an ordinary
Puerto Rican rum too
which Barrilito 3 stars.
There are a number, I don't
have time to go into the number.
The number of ordinary rums which
have all the characteristics
of premium rums at
about 1/3 of the price.
This was a display
of Zacapa that ran
for about 4 months
in the Miami Airport.
I happened to use the
Miami Airport a lot.
And so, I was responsible for most
of the sampling there
for four months.
No rough aftertaste.
Good rums invite repetition.
They should go down smoothly,
very, very, smoothly.
And one of the characteristics
is that you cannot get smoothness
if the alcohol content
is above 86 proof.
You'll get some of these 88, 90, 92,
you should be suspicious about that.
The perfect proofage for
suavity is between 80 and 86.
That means that half of
the proofage is the amount,
the percentage the alcohol is,
so 80 proof rum is 40% alcohol.
I think that if you drink
things that are 120, 160 proof,
you're committing suicide.
There's no way the liver can
handle that sort of thing.
But most of the people
who drink that type of rum
or either alcoholics or
they drink it with water.
Now the other thing is that
rums need no special language
like winemakers.
You know, the taste
of fresh mote hay.
If you want to taste the
fresh mote hay, go eat hay.
That's why we never
talk about tasting rums.
We talk about sampling rums.
Because you know you go to the wine
market and you bring your cheese
and you bring your bread and you
get your thing and you swish it
and you do all this sort of ritual
and then you spit it out, naw,
that's not for the rum guy.
You drink and drink
until you hear the click
and you are oblivious
of what is around you.
Rums are sampled, not tasted.
So here is a testimony,
I don't know,
do I have time to yes, to read.
I don't know if you can read it,
because you can read
it, I love this.
There are 7,800 labels of
rum in the world at least,
that's the last time
I looked at the rums.
Made in 181 countries and this
guy is waxing poetic over one rum
which came from Anguilla, a tiny
island that produces no sugar
but that's not against it.
Most places that produce
rum do not grow sugar cane,
so it's not surprising.
Today, most rum including, I
suspect most of the Caribbean rums,
a lot of the North American
rums are from alcohol.
Brazil is a major supplier,
South African, Australia, Vienna.
All the others tend to buy the
stalk or buy the sugar cane.
So can I move on?
Yes, that's what it is.
I hate to tell him because
this is about 4 or 5 years old,
that Pirate is no longer
bottled in Anguilla.
It's bottled in Vienna,
but it's still a good rum,
still an authentic rum.
So here I'm just running
through some of the countries
and again you can go online
when this is up on the Library
of Congress web and pick your rum.
These are both normal batch rums
which are, but the batch rums here,
like the Barrilito from
Puerto Rico, 3 stars are rums
which measure up or Flor de Cana.
The ordinary Flor de Cana
rum is a remarkable rum and
yet it's not a premium rum.
Flor de Cana makes a 12 and
14 year old rum which is well.
If Christianity gave that
instead of milk and honey,
they would have a lot more
affiliates around the world.
Here, another list, I just
thought I would give you a choice
if you want to get it.
But I don't select or recommend the
best rum and I have said I won't do
that until somebody
pays me to say that.
Then you will get my number 1.
But usually I give a
range of good rums.
If you find a rum that you
like, that's a good rum.
Buy it and drink it.
If it has all the qualities as a
premium rum that I have indicated,
then you're home for good.
And they can come from
anywhere you want.
I haven't really got
into the Australian
and South African rums yet.
I've had a few.
They're really, really good
or some that I have tasted,
but I need to get a range of them.
And then there is a good
bibliography for those of you
who thought that I was just
speaking from elevated stimulation.
But I actually did some
reading as well as drinking.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Can we get some lights so I can see?
Yes.
>> Ah me?
>> Yeah, yeah, you're number 1.
>> I wanted to say that first
of all I had the pleasure
of sampling rum with Joyce Spence.
>> Oh you can't get any better.
Joyce, for those of you, Joyce
Spence was the first female blender
in a major rum maker in the
world, J. Wray and Nephew
in Jamaica, Appleton Estate Special.
When she was appointed,
I remember it well.
There was doom and gloom from
all quarters of [inaudible]
that appreciated good rum.
They'd say this is the
end of a good label.
She is the one that
developed the blue label,
21 year old and some others.
There are only two female blend,
she has a PhD in chemistry,
so she has the credentials,
most of the other people
are sniffing and snorting.
Sorry I take that back, no
political reference here please.
But a lot of it is you know,
the father to son tradition
of declaring that sort of quality.
Yes. You were going
to say something else.
>> My question is, even though
well she did give me a nice bottle
of rum, Ron Diaz or
something like that.
>> Yes, very special.
>> We sat under the trees of Devon
House, sampled rum, she said,
never put anything in your rum
except a little coconut water
or ginger beer but
never a Cuba Libre.
>> Well, I'll agree with that.
I myself think that Coca Cola is
supposed to be a rust remover.
And so I don't drink Cuba Libre, but
a mojito, now that's something else.
In fact, I walk around with my
own recipe for making mojito.
And in Cuba when you know,
I will say to someone,
this is not very good and say
it's a Cuban thing and then I whip
out my little nice
special mojito recipe.
They say, el sabe, el sabe, he
knows, he knows and they want it.
>> Yep, mm-hm.
>> With all that good
wonderful rum in Jamaica,
why do people prefer the
Wray and Nephew white rum?
It's in everybody's house.
>> Yeah but that's true
everywhere that rum is consumed,
as I mentioned, 80% of the rum.
Look at Australia, white
rum is the rum consumed.
And I think mainly because a little
bit is the addictive quality.
They're not drinking it for
the qualities we are finding
of batch rums and premium rums,
they're drinking it for the alcohol.
It's like smoking cigarettes
for the nicotine
and so some of them will blend it.
But you know, with white rum
you can only get it stronger
or weaker, there's no subtlety.
What develops in the aging is
subtlety in the batch ordinary rums,
mostly in the premium rums because
something new is introduced.
In fact, they're even now
making some sort of bourbon
and putting Sherry in
it to make it gentle.
Yes.
>> Could you tell me
a little bit about rum
and temperance in this country?
Because rum seems to
have been singled
out [inaudible] than other drinks.
>> Probably because, yes
it was called Kill Devil
from the 16th Century.
Richard Ligon writes about it.
And it was the most popular drink
in the United States until 1913,
so that all the things that
we now identify with bourbon
or White Lightning
or Southern Comfort
for example was made with rum.
And since rum was the most
popular distilled alcohol consumed,
it got the fire.
Now in 1913, between 1913 and 1930
when prohibition was repealed,
a lot of underground
operations took flight
and rum never recovered after that.
First of all, American bourbon
whiskey developed, White Lightning
and all these poisonous stuff
that they, to which we owe NASCAR
and other types of things.
[ Inaudible ]
Which advertised itself a
long time, a scotch whiskey.
It was made in the Bahamas in
Bermuda, never came from Scotland,
never had nothing Scottish
in it at all or later
on we get whiskeys made
in Panama and so on.
But the temperance movement
really did affect rum
but not alcohol consumption.
So beers came up, although
they tried you know
for a number of years
until recently.
In a lot of states you couldn't
have beers which were stronger
than 4% alcohol, 3% was the average.
You couldn't have wines which
were more than 11% alcohol.
Today wines are up to 17% alcohol.
They've been creeping up
and beers up to 8% alcohol,
but a good beer is usually
up to usually about 6%.
Yeah, yes.
>> I have a question that kind
of follows up on this earlier,
a question about what
the locals drink.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And what the cheap stuff is.
So, my parents, probably
about 4 years ago used
to go to Bermuda on vacation.
It was a time when I think Gosling's
was even on the market in the US.
>> Oh, okay.
I was just going to
say Gosling's has been
around for a long time
yes, in Bermuda, yes.
Dark and stormy, yeah, mm-hm.
>> Just ordinary folks
drank in large quantities.
>> Oh yes.
>> But on side of white
rum it's not the stuff
that comes straight
out of the still.
But I'm kind of suspecting based
on what you're saying today
that it's not dark, because
it's been aged in wood,
it's dark because something
has been added into it?
>> Yeah, it's caramel.
It's burnt sugar.
>> Okay.
>> In Gosling's and it's aged not
necessarily, especially Gosling's,
not necessarily in oak
cask because you're putting
in the caramel to give it the color.
You can put in plastic and steel.
The same way that you know,
in Argentina until the 1990s
they aged their red wines.
Then of course when the
Chileans told them you know,
put in oak cask is
better, they caught on.
But you know, I think the rum
that the buccaneers and pirates
and others were drinking
was white rum.
It was ac -- Only accidently
that they found that putting it,
aging it which was
accidental too improved it.
And the casks they had were
thrown away casks from wines
or ales or things like that.
And as I said, several of
them paid the price for using.
Yes, the improper containers.
>> So is this practice of
adding in stuff like caramel,
is that what you're referring
to as the weekend aging.
>> Yeah, well it's, yes and in
fact there's a movement trying
to legitimize it saying
that you shouldn't be
against caramel coloring because
it is, the caramel is the sugar
and sugar comes from the sugar cane.
But of course you can get caramel
for all sorts of other
things as well.
But more and more they're
just coloring it artificially.
And they, if you can
infuse it with items
of certain things you
can trick the palate
into believing it's actually
the same chemical things.
But it breaks down almost invariably
when you artificially constitute
the color and the bouquet
and things, they just fall out.
>> Hm, thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> What is the richest
rum to other drinks
that are distilled
sugar, like [inaudible]?
>> Well there's lots
of other [inaudible],
there's sugar in alcohol
versus fruit alcohol.
So, but the basic alcohol
is the same whether it's
from the sugar cane or apples or
grain or whatever else they do.
When I was a teenager, we tried to
make, I went to boarding school.
We tried to make alcohol in
the chemistry lab from chips,
not knowing it was very poisonous.
Luckily it blew up
before we could sample it.
So we were saved.
Later we learned that was a
very dangerous thing to do
because had we succeeded and we were
close to it, it would be lethal,
because it's not ethanol
alcohol which is the type
of alcohol which is consumable.
Yes. Yes.
>> I'm not a drinker from.
>> A pity.
>> I know.
>> But I have a weak head.
To get a good rum, how much would
it cost in the United States?
>> Oh there's a great wine shop
on Wisconsin Ave and Elm Street
and you can get a rum there for $20.
You can get a good
premium rum for $30.
Now they have a lot
for 50 and so on.
But no, you can get
a good ordinary rum.
You look for Barrilito [inaudible]
or you look for Flor de Cana.
I think they have both and I think
you're talking 18 to $22 for that
and it's marvelous and smooth.
It has all the characteristics I
talk about at 1/3 of the price.
That's it.
I thank you for your
attention and again I apologize
that you have to take
my word for it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.